yay team white its try Knight f3 might
try a Kings Indian attack Kings Indian
attack okay let's see well that's the
setup really that I'm gonna go forward
with let's see how black reacts to it
these moves that I'm playing is white
are pretty universal King side fin keto
castle and ensuing moves like d3 and
then try to establish upon an e4 often
needing well it would need additional
support now my first thought being
perfectly honest my first thought was to
play age three and throw a question of
this guy and the candidate move without
a doubt my other thought is trying to
exploit the weakened square b7 because
he's not around to watch over it a
typical reaction are a typical idea with
this setup for white is to put pressure
on d5 with c5 having already been played
I can rule out that black will have c6
dreamforce d5 of course so c4 is a
candidate move as well as h three and
i'm looking to just maybe do this right
away or even 95 let's be most direct i
think this is most direct i'm not going
to play h3 i might want to plant my
knight in the center with tempo against
the bishop maybe that's a reason in
other words not go forward with h3 maybe
there's a way to centralize the night
hit something over here maybe out d 7 or
c6 and the bishop on g4 so let's see how
black responds to this strike in the
center if black is another thing that
has my attention
is how many moves black is from castling
they still need how many moves quite a
bit 13 moves i'm already castled so i'm
looking at moves which are going to help
advance the pieces that i have deployed
already and by doing that or how i could
do that is to create pond exchanges
however i'm liking night here right now
right here right now because this bishop
has to do what he's got to go home I'm
pretty sure he's got to go home yeah I'm
pretty sure that night all right now
this bishop has to go home I don't know
that you could really allow me to take
this bishop if I'm allowed to take this
bishop I could follow up with e3 strike
at the center and hit the night okay now
the queen is tethered to the defense of
the bishop there's not a way to exploit
the Queen's position maybe I keep this
as is maybe be 5v5 is something that I'm
thinking about Queen a4 check is another
actually I think I like that yeah let me
give check a for check I have these two
squares covered you can't go here making
the king will that's bad news however
you slice it i'm also out of this pin
one of my thoughts was to try and get an
e3 but i couldn't for as long as my
Queens on her home square how will black
defend you can't throw the night here i
have three pieces guarding Black only
has two defending one of the nights here
or the bishop here actually this night
can't go here it's just dropping this
and this night goes here which means
that this Bishop is now not going to be
recaptured with the Queen so this night
is also pinned my pond is being attacked
right now I think I pick up this Bishop
and then open things up pick up the
bishop break at this pawn maybe the D
file opens up maybe I break at this pond
I like just taking this and I'm going to
challenge this pawn on me know I'm going
to challenge this pawn I might want to
go for a gambit right here yeah let's
let's do this be four if takes so this
is a very Benko gambit like okay and I
guess Bishop 83 yeah Bishop a three if
I'm if my opponent captured I was
considering a three just to open the a
and B files and I'm really trying to do
I'm really trying to put pressure on b7
I already have the bishop converging on
this pond and as soon as a brook is
played to be which seems to be a
difficult thing to get working I think
this could turn out to be quite good for
me so this night is not really a problem
i'm not concerned about the pressure has
on h2 + f2 all right now I'm just
regarding it as out of play and do i
take i think i do this night isn't a pin
and actually what is it that black would
like to be doing black would like to be
castling but after Bishop takes Bishop
takes Queen takes black is still not in
a position to castle because of the
pinned the pin night in fact I could be
winning this pun but you know what I
might not even want to do that can win
this pond the rook plays here I want to
just advance my development I'm actually
seeing me advancing my development as
being best night 83 looking at b5
looking at just rookie won this pond is
in a pin it really can't go far might be
five to see 7 or d6 stuff it coupled
with maybe c5 letting a support point on
d6 this could be a problem and maybe
they're still going to be tactics
against this night for example bishop h
three hits the night and the one on d7
indirectly I do have some time to be
making up let's see about this rook a2
b1 okay this
pond has some yes if watch over this i
think let's just go with something here
in fact now I'm in a spot to double
rooks rook beefs b5 just getting all my
pieces working and already functioning
laterally so it's not enough once you
get to the that point in your own chess
game where you know to put your Brooks
on an open file well that next step they
look for is what they can do along a
rank and b5 is a good point to be
hitting at in fact it controls blacks
it's in blacks territory it's hitting
all fifth-ranked squares directly or
indirectly I guess you can say that with
any move really directly or indirectly
but it's it's doing a lot from this
square okay so the king is on Castle how
do i exploit that well first and
foremost let's get my rook working I'd
like to maybe get on this diagonal I
like to get on the same diagonal as the
king of course I could have taken this
poem that should have been my first my
first thought but ok let's let's see
what the Queen does like maybe maybe
taking here is better hmm let me take
this night away do I give a check let me
give a check if the Queen blocks I kick
the Queen away I could grab this pond
maybe I should do that but how should i
do that i have two different ways to do
it take with the rook maybe that's
leading to two men ok now this rook is
not going to be around to help out busy
no he's now i think i want to take with
the bishop you take with the bishop
and when my bishop retreats taking with
the bishop um i think for a couple
reasons but the one that's i'm able to
verbalize right now is so that when I
retweet when I read tree I almost said
retweet again when i read tree if flip
take struck i capture with the pot and
then i have c4 Vale where my opponent is
coming at me right now we put pressure
on this night deter that h4 move
actually no not forget about the pond i
want to be even more direct i'll take
with the night rook takes rook i take
with the night okay we're not having
that but that night is that night has
some problem this rook has to go
somewhere else pawn push is coming up my
nights going to be jumping in to d6 very
soon by way of c4 and this is this is
going to be game over my bishops hit i
think i could just take the night even
opening up the h5 i don't think that's
going to be an issue although no no
reason to even react just yet I'm
hitting the queen with the pond I'll
just take and now there's no way to
defend this i can i can always another
thing i can always defend if the Queen
if you could envision the Queen I one of
these three I can always play h4 but in
this case right here the pieces are just
coming up and hang on hang on that was
almost a bad decision right there by me
to go after that rook right there would
not have been a good thing because that
pot heads up promoting my Knights not
even there to defend and then we are
just in the mopping up phase tricky
Knights picking up everything watch out
for stalemate it's my last concern no
stalemates right here and here no matter
what just get the rooks off no stalemate
here no matter what here no matter what
no time
okay good game let me flip this board
and let's go back and see how either one
of us could have improved let's see well
i think i think the bulk of this what
I'm about to say is really the things
that I've already said during the game
they'll to be very cautious about the
early deployment of this light square
Bishop and the weakening regard c5 as
weakening d5 and no actually it could
view it as just weakening the light
square diagonal you don't have c6
anymore to reinforce d5 and if you if d5
is broken at if you cannot maintain
control over d5 then you lose the right
to really control c6 there's a domino
effect you don't control c6 so easily be
7 and that really turned out to be a big
target these are light squares on in
this section of the board in this
quadrant the queenside queen coming out
the pressure on b7 with first the bishop
later with the rook it became too much
to bear so what am i getting out maybe I
mean I'm not saying that this is wrong
but I think playing the Bishop g4 is
maybe a step in the wrong direction
maybe something like knight c6 is going
to be better not yet declaring your
bishops intentions maybe knight c6 is
going to be a better option right here
then at least you know you're not having
to deal with Nike 5 with tempo that's
eventually what ends up happening isn't
it right here I get here with tempo but
if your night is on c6 not the case so
at least have this knight on c6 if you
really are going to go forward with this
make sure your night is on c6 and I
don't have this 95 tempo on your bishop
and as soon as I have that light square
Bishop things became much simpler for me
this night is out of play
is there something on these two and
there's not he's just out of play and
I'm looking to open up I'm looking to
target b7 with the rook and it becomes
difficult to defend b5 you're trying to
get your development in i'm getting my
development in and now you're tied down
you want to be able to castle but you're
having difficulty with this and b7 it's
just too much to deal with so that's my
main suggestion really out of the gates
and the deployment of the pieces in the
move order in which you play them
instead of again Bishop g4 considered
the nights before the night going with
the night before the bishop knight c6
and then maybe even want to do III may
be bringing the bishop out is something
you don't want to do something more calm
like getting you're making sure you can
get your king castle quickly with e6 to
reinforce this pond Bishop e7 castle but
probably knight c6 right here okay